what's going on everybody welcome to the
quadcopter video
in this video i'm just gonna be showing
you guys the first attempt
at my quadcopter restraint system that
i've got going on here so
actually right behind me you can see my
quadcopter
now what i've done is at the ceiling
i've got it
uh connected to the ceiling there's a
stud in the ceiling and i've got a
hook that's on the ceiling i've got
these bungee cords with the little
i don't know what the official thing is
like a grappling hook that people use
for like climbing
uh i've got those then i've got two 20
pound weights that it's
underneath mostly the reason i'm using
two is one to kind of act almost like a
pulley system
uh so we can shorten the length of that
of one of them
now as time goes on i might want to let
it actually free fly a little bit
right now i kind of want a lot of
restraint on it just uh just for safety
now i've got around 15 zippy ties
connecting the hooks i couldn't really
find any better way to do it besides
zippy ties
each point of failure has well on the
top we've got
four zippy ties for um
for points of failure so it would cost
take a lot of zip ties to break before
this thing uh would fall to the floor
and on the bottom we've just got two zip
ties for points of
failure but i'm a little less concerned
about the bottom as i am
the top when it falls if it goes to the
ceiling i don't really care if it hits
the fan or whatever i'll just repaint
but mostly i'm concerned about the
things you know left right and all that
and the top will protect that even from
hitting the window from hitting the tank
over there and all that so
anyway we're going to go ahead and start
this up i've had enough problems with it
already i
the first propeller adapter these things
that go right on the top here
the first one of those was bad it was
like
not necessarily i guess it wasn't it was
like threaded to death
and so i was like over threaded it
didn't work got another one
and then i was torquing these on and i
ripped the top off as i torqued it so
i had to get another one so i've had a
really hard time also if you haven't
noticed i'm actually in my new place
uh maybe i'll show a picture of it from
the doorway or something i've got my
whole set up here
my tv and stereo and stuff over there
it's quite nice to have all this new
space got a new house
um so yeah maybe i'll do a series on the
house or something or the room at least
the man cave
so without further ado let's go ahead
and power this thing up hopefully it'll
work
the last time i powered it up i couldn't
even get it to arm i had to
you know recycle through all of the
processes but uh
hopefully we'll be all set also i got a
dog in here i'm going to try and
convince him to leave
not very safe to have him in here plus
he probably won't like it
so let me go ahead and escort him on out
and we'll go ahead and get started
all right let's do this final check
before we plug it in
make sure we got some good play here
now eventually if it pulls this hard
like the handle of the weight
is kind of curved so it might slip a
little bit that might cause me to piss
my pants but
that should be fine so let's go ahead
and get this thing started
apparently we're let's see
switcher one of our switches is probably
there we go
okay now we're ready to go so we got
that let's plug this thing in
all right that sounds like it's on so
i had some better protection besides
these glasses
don't have any protective eyewear
probably should get some of that
but we're not going to go too crazy
today plus we're not autonomous before
we go autonomous probably should get
some of that
and maybe even make a setup in the
garage instead of in my room
uh got a lot of screens there's what
well six screens on this wall
so anyway
so we got a lot of tilt going on
and that's actually uh to the side
so we definitely need to calibrate that
a little bit but
as far as the restraint system is
concerned that's quite nice i'm happy
with that
all right that is going to get dangerous
fast